hi I am dr. amit kapoor from institute
for competitiveness india you know I've
been talking about States or listening
about the states the fundamental thing
that the Indian states need to do is
that they need to have their own agenda
in terms of what growth they should do
what kind of industries they should
focus on there has to be a clear-cut
positioning that each state needs to
take up right now what we see in it see
in India is that India is growing at
about nine percent or eight percent
whatever we might say but this about ten
states which are growing at a rate which
is higher than the way India's growing
so that means there is certain dichotomy
in the way the growth is actually
happening there is a whole huge level of
disparity in the growth of states and if
you really see what these states need to
do is that they really need to define
then what genders they are really going
to follow if they do not do that they're
actually going to get lagging behind the
second thing that we really need to
understand and look at is something on
urbanization how the organization will
happen what kind of cities are really
going to come up right now we are just
too focused on certain set of city said
Delhi Bombay or what we might follow the
tier 1 cities the growth in the country
is not really going to happen from these
cities it's actually going to be about
the alternate cities that are really
going to be coming up so if you really
look at a state like Maharashtra you
would notice that about the six to eight
urban centers contributed about ninety
percent of the gdp to the state of
Maharashtra and let the true story
across the board so the urban areas are
really going to create a lot of
opportunities but we need to go for
right urbanization and that's going to
be very important for competitiveness of
the country I think what's happening
right now is that we growth that we're
seeing in the urban areas is actually
fairly not very well planned and so on
and so forth so there are going to be
certain level of delamination factors
that are really going to be coming in in
fact if you really talk about the cities
that we're seeing which are going to
emerge they're going to be like say Unga
bod which is going to be an alternate
city a place like gold on is going to go
down Bangalore is going to go down
because the denomination factors have
already set in so each city should look
at the larger point is that each city
and state should develop its own
economic agenda its own positioning and
then focus on it in fact that the larger
thing would be that each state should
actually look at the top three
industries that they should be focusing
on today's states are not completing
just within states in India they're
going to be competing with it with
different locations across the world and
if you do not get it right the states
are actually going to lose it so I think
the primary thing for the Chief Minister
is going to be actually to get the
fiscal policy right to get their growth
agendas right and focus on development
just leaving behind the petty politics
that the very things are happening
thanks